The neurons connecting the ear to the brain are complete at around 18 weeks
after conception. So, does this mean a fetus can hear before it's born? The
answer's yes. The auditory neural connections are made by about 18 weeks. But,
the fetus doesn't start responding to sound until about 26 weeks or six months
after conception. Fetuses actually find their mother's voice soothing and
prefer the sound of the mother's voice over other voices. One example is
researchers monitored the fetus' heart rate and found that it slowed when
hearing the mother's voice, which showed that the fetus was able to attend or
orient to its mother's voice. And it could calm him or her. However, an
increase in heart rate would indicate fear or distress, and that doesn't happen
when a fetus hears his own mother's voice.